hey everyone its Johanna here burgers
hotdogs and french fries are just some
of our favorite fast foods according to
a recent article on Huffington Post
Americans eat nearly 50 billion burgers
a year and according to a survey done by
the national hot dog and sausage council
they estimate that Americans eat an
average of 20 billion hot dogs a year
and on top of that the average Americans
consume about 29 pounds of french fries
in a year taking in consideration that
all these surveys and research are only
based on Americans we as a whole consume
a lot more burgers hot dogs and french
fries worldwide hence that's why the
global fast food sales are projected to
reach 259 point seven billion dollars
this year while I do enjoy my occasional
fast foods they never leave me feeling
good afterwards
I tend to feel really bloated that's
because fast foods are high in sodium
sugar unhealthy fat high in calories and
there are no nutritional values
whatsoever so instead of avoiding them
we want to be making our own healthier
version of burgers hot dogs and french
fries let's go back to the basic of fast
foods and use minimal ingredients with
high nutritional values what I have here
is a store-bought veggie burger let's
take a look at the ingredients carrot
11% beans 6% wheat protein so I
concentrated stabilizer flavor and Hansa
color gelling agent right too many too
complicated to make a healthy and
delicious veggie burger you will only
need seven basic ingredients we
you can change and adapt according to
your own preference and taste the seven
ingredients are rolled oats choose your
beans either red beans black beans
chickpeas choose your vegetables either
carrots bell peppers spinach choose your
sauce sweet chili sauce tomato sauce or
barbecue sauce
choose your herbs or spice cumin chili
powder or even paprika and of course
onion and garlic to bring all the
flavors together to make my sweet chili
veggie burger the ingredients I have
chosen are 1/3 cup of rolled oats 1 can
of chickpeas rinsed and drained 1 medium
carrot grated 1 tablespoon of sweet
chilli sauce 1/2 a teaspoon of chili
powder 1/2 a teaspoon of cumin cut a cup
of onion diced 2 cloves of garlic minced
and season with salt and pepper the
first step is to place oats carrots
onions and garlic into the food
processor process until all the
ingredients are finely minced then add
the chickpeas and process until the
chickpeas are mashed and well blended
with all the mixtures finally add your
chosen sauce and spices and continue to
process transfer the mixture into a bowl
and stir well to make sure that all the
sources and spices are combined and all
the chickpeas are meshed next preheat
the oven to 180 degrees Celsius or 350
degree Fahrenheit
coats a baking tray with a little bit of
cooking spray using your hands divide
the mixture into six equal sized
portions roll them into balls and
flatten them to make sixth patties each
Patty should be about quarter to half of
an inch high place the patties on the
baking tray and bake for 30 minutes
after 15 minutes flip the patties over
and bake for the remaining 15 minutes
until the patties are lightly browned
and crispy on the outside all this
ingredients used are edible without
to bake them so if you want to store
your veggie burgers don't bake them
place them in a container and freeze
them up when you are ready to eat then
bake them this will last you up to six
months if you are not a big fan of oats
don't worry the oats are only used to
find all the ingredients together you
will not taste the oats at all instead
you will be adding more nutritional
values to your burger
each veggie burger only has 85 0.33
calories and I've serve mine with muffin
buns so pick your ingredients start to
experiment and make your own healthy
veggie burger do let me know your
version of healthy veggie burger in the
comments below most fast food hotdogs
are high in unhealthy fat hence being
high in calories as well
Mylene hotdog is low in fat and high in
protein the key is to choose extra lean
ground meat when you buy your ground
meat go for a 95% lean meat and 5% fats
here are two packs of minced meat one is
extra lean with 95 percent of lean meat
and only 5% of fat the value pack has 77
percent of needs with 23 percent of fat
the extra lean meat only has 128
calories per 100 gram as for the value
pack it has 276 calories per 100 gram
that's more than twice the amount of
calories that's because one gram of fat
has nine calories and one gram of
protein has four calories price
difference the extra lean meat is only
one pound more expensive so save your
waistline and save your health by
choosing extra lean meat the ingredients
you need to make my lean hotdogs are
quarter cup of rolled oats 250 gram of
extra lean means meat either pork turkey
the
a lamb or chicken one large egg white
lightly beaten two cloves of garlic
minced quarter cup of onion diced half a
teaspoon of dried mixed herbs half a
teaspoon of paprika and season with salt
and pepper the first step is to grind
the oats in a food processor and to find
and set it aside
then place the minced meat in the food
processor and process until very fine
add the oats egg white onion and garlic
and process until you have a paste
finally add the mix herbs paprika and
season with salt and pepper pulse the
mixture for another 30 seconds to
combine all the ingredients evenly
transfer the mixture into a bowl cover
and chill in the fridge for 45 minutes
to an hour once the mixture is chill
divide into five equal sized portions
shape and roll each portion between your
hands to form a four to five inches long
lock do not roll the hotdogs too thin
because without the casing they might
break apart when cooking
next place the hotdogs in a pan then add
enough water to cover almost halfway out
of the meat bring to a boil and then
reduce the heat to medium and simmer
gently turn the hotdogs occasionally
until they are thoroughly cook for about
15 minutes then remove and a lot of hot
dogs to cool down at this point you can
choose to bake or grill your hotdogs
like what I've done here and serve
immediately as for the remaining hotdogs
stall them in a container and keep them
in the fridge for up to two days or you
can freeze them up for up to six months
this hotdog is packed full of protein
extremely low in fat and each serving
has ninety three point four calories I
served it with multigrain roll and this
is a great post-workout meal
if you want to make hamburgers you can
use the exact same ingredients and just
make the paste into a burger like shape
I've also served a sign of the sweet
potato fries with both my veggie burger
and hot dogs french fries
one of the unhealthiest foods with high
amount of salt trans fat and calories
they are deep fried loaded with oil and
has no nutritional values whatsoever to
have a healthy side of fries let's
choose sweet potatoes instead and more
importantly to oven baked instead of
deep-frying to make a classic sweet
potato fries the ingredients you need
are 250 gram of sweet potatoes peeled
and cut into wedges 1 TSP of olive oil
1/2 a teaspoon of paprika and 1/2 a
teaspoon of cumin you may also choose
any other spices of your choice preheat
the oven to 200 degrees Celsius or 400
degree Fahrenheit in a bowl toss
together all the ingredients until
potatoes are evenly coated with oil and
spices then spread potatoes on a single
layer on the baking tray bake for a
total of 25 to 30 minutes after 15
minutes turn them over and return to the
oven and bake for another 10 to 15
minutes until they are well browned and
serve so the next time you're craving
for a fast food meal go into the kitchen
and make your own healthy fast food
instead these fast foods are high in
nutritional values and they taste even
better so be good to your body for new
Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
You Tube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
Oh